*Musique du générique*
Squeezie : C'est incroyable ce qu'il se passe
On a le meilleur public du monde, merci !
Est-ce que vous pouvez le refaire juste pour le kiff ? C'est parti :
*Cris du public*
On va pas tarder
à accueillir les streamers
je vais pas redire leurs noms super vite parce que c'est très chiant
Mais j'aimerais un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour l'équipe : LE STREAM !!!
*Musique épique*
*Musique épique* Ils sont là !
Je suis très heureux que vous soyez là , ça me fait hyper plaisir
Vous avez remarqué quelque chose ?
c'est que Cyprien n'est pas là
mais il nous a fait une petite vidéo !
pour se faire pardonner
on la regarde ensemble.
Cyprien : Bonjour à tous, malheureusement je ne suis pas présent,
puisque je suis à l'étranger, mais je suis de tout
cœur avec vous pour le
premier prime du Stream
je serai présent pour le prochain prime
en tout cas amusez-vous bien pour ce premier prime
mettez le feu, à très vite.
Squeezie : Merci Cyprien pour ton message
on l'applaudit.
*applaudissements*
J'adore !
Je me prends vraiment pour un présentateur
Bon les amis ça va être la folie, ce soir.
Il y a deux invités qui ont acceptés de nous rejoindre.
(Musique d'ouverture d'un coffre dans Zelda)
Laink et Terracid !!!!!!!
*cris du public*
Venez par là, venez me dire bonjour ! (Putain)
Qu'est-ce que vous êtes beaux !
Les gars merci de nous avoir rejoint !
Maintenant je vais laisser place à quelqu'un de l'équipe qui va présenter tous les prochains primes,
son nom c'est Maxildan on l'applaudit !
*applaudissements*
Maxildan : Bon bah merci à toi Lucas
de nous avoir introduit un petit peu
LeStream ici
eh ben je vous propose effectivement comme tu disais
qu'on commence tout de suite avec, du fun !
Du jeu !
Nos deux capitaines d'équipe ce soir sont évidement
Squeezie
et *blblblblbllll* Mickalow !
*applaudissements*
Messieurs vous allez pouvoir commencer à choisir les membres de vos équipes.
Moi, je choisis toujours un petit costaud....
Nico, allez !
Allez, Nico (alias Nameless), on peut applaudir bien fort!
Il faut un mec stock...
Il a prit un mec stock, il me faut un mec stock.
Zouloux, merci de me rejoindre !
*applaudissements*
On passe tout de suite à Micka, ton deuxième joueur ?
On va prendre un petit complot...
P'tit complot de H1Z1...
Un p'tit pote...
ZANKIOH !
Allez !
*applaudissements*
Bah moi j'vais rester dans le H1Z1...
Et je vais prendre GOTAGA !
Allez !
*applaudissements*
T'as vu, à chaque fois j'ai un counter !
dès que tu me piques un truc, j'te contre !
Eh bien, est-ce que tu vas pouvoir counter son troisième pick ?
C'est l'anaconda algérien, on me dit dans l'oreillette
Oh là! *rire*
Jiraya qui sera donc ton quatrième joueur ici
Squeezie comment tu counter ce fameux anaconda ?
Je vais prendre Xari
Oh ça prend...
ça prend le duo
Cinquième
Moi je dis, y'a un mec il est tout seul là, assis
Y'a un petit dernier de la classe ici
Moi je l'aurais pris, il est là tout seul comme ça
On s'amuse
Yannou !
Viens nous montrer tes Air Jordan
Comment tu counter Yann
Il me fait les yeux, Sky me fait les yeux doux
Vas-y Sky viens, j'ai eu pitié vas-y
Mickalow, c'est à ton tour
Alors, qui tu prends ?
Trinity
Trinity !
Bon du coup je prend l'autre fille, Manamy
Merci
On applaudit bien fort s'il-vous-plaît dans le public
*applaudissement du public*
Il nous reste Laink et Terracid
Venez là, venez là, venez au milieu les amis
Venez au milieu
C'est évidement Micka qui va avoir l'honneur de choisir le premier
Fais très attention, l'autre sera vexé
Moi en vrai les gars
Moi je prends Terracid
Allez voilà !
Ça c'est fait
*rire*
C'est mal joué
Est-ce que vous avez des idées de noms pour votre équipe, très très vite
par pitié un nom intelligent
C'est trouvé ?
Ok, on a des riches chez nous
du coup on lance la YouTube money
Et on s'appellera "20 centimes (vingt cent Team)" mon pote
C'est incroyable
Nous on a pas osé faire de jeux de mot
On s'est juste appelé la "Tim Burton (Team Burton)", voilà c'est tout pour moi
*rires*
Voilà on part sur ça
Premier jeu, c'est tout simplement
Une épreuve que vous pouvez retrouver dans certaines salles d'arcade
On a carrément déplacé une salle d'arcade sur le plateau
Squeezie : Allez Mika vient là !
J't'affronte mon gars !
Maxildan : Très bien les deux capitaines d'équipes qui vont s'affronter
Il vous faut un coéquipier chacun
Mika : Genre il a envie de perdre quoi
Squeezie : OK OK, je vois. Qui est fort au basket?
Xari : Moi j'suis fort de ouf !
Squeezie : Eh ben Xari viens
C'est une très belle candidature
Maxildan : Très bien, merveilleux ! Alors du coup on aura Squeezie et Xari dans une équipe
Et on aura Mickalow et ? Oh laisse moi deviner
Squeezie : Est-ce qu'on peut deviner? On laisse le public deviner
Qui fait du basket et adore faire des vidéos sur le jeu NBA 2K, sur YouTube ?
Public : Yann!
Et oui!!! C'est Yannou
Mickalow : On va se mettre bien là !
Maxildan : Du coup vous allez être tous les deux
Et là j'explique un petit peu ce qui va se passer, on se déplace par là.
Et vous allez voir la surprise après le jingle, aller c'est parti !
*Musique*
Maxildan : Alors ce qu'on va faire, c'est  qu'on va mettre une petite difficulté supplémentaire: vous allez être attachés dos à dos
Et chacun votre tour vous allez devoir marquer un panier,
laisser votre pote marquer un panier  et continuer à tourner et vous tournez toujours dans le même sens
Aller on va vous attacher c'est parti
Ok vous pouvez vous approcher de la machine vous allez être les premiers à passer
Vous êtes pas du tout ridicules c'est génial!!
C'est quand vous appuierez sur "play" les ballons vont tomber. Bonne chance à toi!
Et c'est parti!
*musique*
Vraiment une équipe de mort
Mickalow : oh là là! Mais faites un effort!
Laink : C'est dégueu!
Maxildan : Toujours deux paniers pour le moment
On rappelle que les joueurs sont champions du monde
On est à combien là le public?
Et 7!
Allez on les applaudit bien fort ils en ont marqué 7!
Record à battre, 7
Est-ce qu'on peut attacher Mickalow ainsi que Yann
Aller bonne chance c'est hyper dur. Quand vous voulez vous êtes prêts?
Aller plus de 7 paniers messieurs ! Vous avez 60 secondes
*cris d’enthousiasme*
NON !
AIE AIE AIE AIE AIE
Allez!!
Messieurs félicitations vous avez remporté le premier point pour votre équipe la "Vingt cent team"
Vous pouvez les applaudir !
Deuxième jeu c'est encore un jeu que l'on peut trouver dans une salle d'arcade ou plutôt dans les fêtes foraines
C'est un test de force
On va prendre un participant dans chaque équipe, celui qui marque le plus de points remporte la manche
La première équipe qui remporte deux manches remporte ce jeu.
Ça va, c'est simple ? Allez, un joueur dans chaque équipe !
-Tout sauf toi, Squeezie ?
(Squeezie) - Il faut vraiment pas m'envoyer là-dessus
(?) - Pourtant t'as un sacré biceps, quand même, là !
(Squeezie) - Donc je pense qu'on va envoyer Zouloux !
(Max) - Zouloux, on peut l'applaudir !
(Max) - Contre qui va jouer Zouloux, s'il-te-plait Micka ?
(Micka) - Tu sais quoi, j'ai vu il fait un peu le chaud, il va se faire soulever comme à la muscu... Avec Nico mon gars !
(Max) - Allez, Nameless !
(Squeezie) - Le duel de titans...
(Max) - Vous êtes prêts ? A votre avis, qui va gagner, déjà ?
(Nameless) - Alors moi je t'explique, j'ai fait ma séance de muscu hier... J'ai un peu mal, tu vois...
(Max) - Ça cherche des excuses !
(Squeezie) - Ouais mais il va à la muscu du coup !
(Zouloux) - Ouais j'suis pas inquiet.
(Max) - OOH ! Ok c'est parti ! Allez vas-y.
(Max) - On l'encourage s'il-vous-plaît dans le public !
(Squeezie) - On l'encourage !
*encouragements du public*
(Max) - Il faut faire mieux de 873 pour gagner cette manche, à toi. Allez !
(Max) - Oooh... Et c'est une victoire de SuperZouloux !
(Max) - Je vais vous demander de vous rasseoir, et on va prendre deux autres personnes.
(Squeezie) - Eh, je propose un truc ! Je propose un truc, c'est qu'on envoie les filles.
(Max) - Allez, on les encourage, on les encourage.
(Max) - Trinity t'es prête ? Allez on l'encourage vas-y mets-nous une énorme patate là-dedans !
(Zouloux) - Tu crois elle met le genou ?
(Max) - Oh la vache !
(Max) - Tu dois faire mieux que 446, t'as le droit de taper avec la tête si tu veux, mais je te le déconseille.
(Zouloux) - Allez Mana !
(Max) - Pas de tant que ça, pas de tant que ça. Bon on applaudit bien fort !
Et c'est parfait, c'est parfait parce que ça fait une égalité ! Et ça veut dire qu'on va devoir faire... Une troisième manche.
(Squeezie et Max) - J'ai entendu Laink et Terracid !
(Squeezie) - Eh, au pire, faites-le avec la tête ! Voilà, p'tite propal... Faites-le avec votre crâne sinon
(Squeezie) - Avec la tête c'est ok.
(Max) - Est-ce qu'on a les premiers secours, éventuellement ?
(Zouloux) -Est-ce qu'on a les pompiers ?
(Max) - On peut être sur un pétage de nez.
(Squeezie) - Eh ratez pas le truc !
(Mickalow) - On peut descendre la machine pour Laink siouplait ?
*rires et bouh*
(Max) - Ça commence...
(Mickalow) - Regarde il est trop vener !
*encouragements du public*
(Mickalow) - NAN !
*rires*
(Squeezie) - 71 ! C'est pas grave, c'est bien, on l'applaudit !
(Squeezie) - Terra, t'es plus grand, t'as un avantage
*encouragements du public*
(Max) - Allez, on l'applaudit bien fort, bien joué ! Et du coup on gagne un point pour la Team Burton !
(Squeezie) - Oui ! Oui !
(Max) - Vous êtes maintenant à égalité, et on va se marrer maintenant avec un jeu
qui date de 2012 ou de 2002, comme vous préférez. C'est un bottle flip challenge !
*musique du prime*
(Max) - Qui sont nos deux challengers ?
(Squeezie) - On envoie l'homme à la grande vessie pour la Team Burton !
(Max) - Alors, qui sera face à Sky ?
(Mickalow) - Moi j'mets son ancien duo... Jiji !
OOOH!
(Max) - Ok, messieurs vous êtes prêts ? Bonne chance, le timer est prêt derrière. Allez c'est parti !
*musique et rires*
(Mickalow) - Oh, Jiji !
(Tous) - OOOH !
(Max) - Oh là là Sky, il est tellement chaud !
(Mickalow) - Allez Jiji là !!
(Max) - Sky, je pense que tu devrais boire plus, vraiment.
*exclamations*
(Squeezie) - C'est fini les amis, le chrono est à zéro
(Max) - Il y a un partout, du coup il y a égalité
(Squeezie) - Alors on va faire une règle extrêmement simple... Le premier qui fait un bottle flip gagne
(Squeezie) - Allez les gars on y va ! On l'encourage !
(Max) - On l'encourage !
(Squeezie) - Aide pour la Team Burton
(Max) - C'est dégueulasse mais il s'en fout ! Ah dommage pas loin...
(Mickalow) - Jiji vas-y rebois !
(Max) - Voilà rendez-vous demain pour la fin de ce duel, évidemment, j'espère que vous vous éclatez beaucoup !
*exclamations*
(Max) - Et du coup, un point pour... La Vingt Cent Team, qui passe du coup à deux points avec ce troisième challenge.
(Max) - Vous aimez l'eau ? Eh bien on aime beaucoup l'eau, du coup on a mis un deuxième challenge avec de l'eau, et cette fois-ci, c'est le challenge de l'aquarium.
- Qui choisissez-vous pour faire ce jeu ?
(Squeezie) - Il faut un duo qui s'aime et qui font peut-être des vidéos ensemble régulièrement...
- Bon allez Laink et Terracid !
*musique*
(Max) - Bon, c'est très simple, vous avez des billes normalement à votre disposition
Il y en a un qui va prendre les billes noires, l'autre qui va prendre les billes blanches
Vous allez remplir le récipient qui est à l'intérieur, le premier qui fait couler le récipient a perdu.
Allez c'est parti !
(Zankioh) - La tension est à son comble...
(Jiraya) Et le premier échec peut-être... Laink, sois délicat Laink!!
Voilà, c'est ça prends en trois-quatre, c'est ça, n'hésite pas!!!
(Micklow) Oh nan il a pris la grosse !
Oh ! Attends...
(Zankioh)Le "move" interdit! Le move interdit! *exclamations*
OOOH!
Et la technique derrière. La technique!
Attends que ça stabilise
(Zankioh) Oh! Ça tremble un peu
(Jiraya) Aie! Aie! Aie! Aie! Aie! What a move!
Laink en, en petit tueur
Doucement, doucement Laink, ne te presse surtout pas
Oh! Ça commence à flipper. Ça commence à flipper.
(Jiraya) Non ça ne prend pas! Ça prend pas!
"Exclamations*
C'est Tera qui gagne
Quel match! Bien joué! Bien joué messieurs
En vrai Tera il nous a rapporté tous les points.
(Maxildan) Et du coup, on est à deux partout la dessus, puisque c'est une égalisation de la Team Burton. Vous pouvez les applaudir s'il-vous-plait!!
*Musique du prime*
(Maxildan) Alors qui va-t'on envoyer pour jouer à One Two Switch?
Squeezie?
T'est chaud de la traite?
(Squeezie) Je n'ai fait qu'une fois ce jeu...
(Maxildan)Bon messieurs
(Squeezie) C'est mieux que zéro fois
Ah Putain! Il l'a déjà fait six milliards de fois lui
(Maxildan) Donc là le principe est simple:
Vous allez voir un pie de vache
Et vous allez devoir traire cette vache.
Celui qui remplis le plus de verres de lait à gagner
Voilà, vous n'avez pas du tout l'air ridicule
La technique de Jiji! *Rire*
Donc vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi on ne veut pas jouer contre cet homme
(Zankioh) Donne nous toutes tes gouttes!
(Maxildan) Ah! C'est terminé. Attention!
Et victoire de...
De Jiji!
Bon félicitation! Un petit commentaire sur cette défaite?
(Squeezie) Non. Allez
(Maxildan) Voilà, merci. Alors du coup on est d'accord pour dire que c'est effectivement la Vingt Cent Team qui gagne le point sur le jeu
One Two Switch
On les applaudit!
Nous allons passer
au dernier jeu. Voilà de cette émission
Qui est donc un quiz
Le principe est simple: je vais vous poser des questions
Et en faite pour répondre, vous allez devoir "buzzer"
Si vous buzzez, vous devez répondre immédiatement
Si vous parlez avant d'avoir buzzé
Je donne le point à l'équipe adverse
Vous êtes prêts dans le public?
*Cris*
(Squeezie) J'aimerais du bruit pour ceux qui sont pour la Team Burton
(Maxildan) Peut-être pour la Vingt Cent Team?
*Cris*
(Maxildan) En quelle année
Est sortie
Final Fantasy 7?
(Mickalow) 96!
(Maxildan) 96?
C'est une mauvaise réponse, malheureusement
Ahhh! Je t'ai fait une petite feinte, c'est une mauvaise réponse.
(Squeezie) 98?
(Maxildan) Vous êtes juste au bord
C'est évidement 97. *Rires*
(Squeezie) Oh! Non!
(Maxildan) On va passer à la question suivante. Attention concentrez-vous bien.
Écoutez bien!
Quel est le nom
Du compositeur de cette musique
*Musique*
(Jiraya) On va dire John Williams
(Maxildan) Tu as dit John Williams.
(Jiraya) Yes!
(Maxildan) C'est la deuxième personne la plus titrée
Après Walt Disney
C'est John Willams effectivement.
*Exclamations*
Bien joué à toi!
*Son*
On va du coup passer
à la question suivante avec un petit extrait vidéo en prime
Je vais poser la question pendant l'extrait vidéo qui va poper
Attention écoutez bien
Squeezie tu n'as pas le droit de répondre à cette question
C'est une question spéciale
(Squeezie) Ok, je me casse
(Maxildan) D'accord, donc tu ne dis rien. Voilà casses-toi!
Squeezie vient de sortir une vidéo
Dans laquelle il présente l'Esa
Mais que veux dire...
Esa? Que veux dire Esa? E-S-A. On le voit derrière! E-S-A, voilà!
Ah, ça buzzé ici!
(Jiraya) European Astronaut Center
(Maxildan) Et bien ce n'est absolument la bonne réponse
(Squeezie) Zouloux *Buzz*
(Maxildan) À quel moment tu vois un C dans Esa?
(Zouloux) European
Spatial
Astro
Astronaut
(Maxildan) Aucun d'entre vous n'a le point les amis
Tu as dit "Eurpean Astronaut machin
(Jiraya) Je vous ai laissé une chance
(Maxildan) En fait, c'est ça. Vous avez essayé de répondre avec ce qui était écrit sur le panneau derrière
C'était évidement un piège. J'avais regardé avant, je ne suis pas débile
(Jiraya) C'est un piège pour l'équipe adverse
(Maxildan) C'était European Space Agency
La réponse française: L'Agence spatiale européenne était évidement acceptée
On en est où? Quatre pour la Vingt Cent Team
Deux pour la Team Burton. Il va falloir se réveiller ici s'il-vous plait à ma gauche
(Squeezie) Je veux bien, mais tu m'enpêches de répondre.
(Maxildan) C'est vrai!
*Rires*
(Maxildan) Quel est le nom, et vous allez avoir un extrait derrière
Quel est le nom
de l'héroïne
jouée par Chloë Grace Moretz, dans Kick-Ass? Je veux son nom d'héroïne.
Ah! Ça a buzzé.
(Xari) Hit-Girl
(Maxildan) Hit-Girl! C'est une bonne réponse!
Un point pour la Team Burton. C'est ça Xari, finalement tu as la réponse
On va passer à une question jeu vidéo
Un jeu récent
Très récent. Dans quel pays
Se déroule Ghost Recon Wildlands?
(Zouloux) La Bolivie
(Maxildan) La Bolivie! C'est une bonne réponse de Super-Zouloux
Et c'est une égalisation de la Team Burton
Applaudissez-les fort s'il-vous-plait
*Exclamations*
(Squeezie) Et heureusement les op Ubisoft, hein, il ne l'aurait jamais sû sinon.
(Maxildan) Nous allons cette fois-ci parler de high-tech
Pour ceux qui sont un petit peu chaud sur tout ce qui est montage PC et etc. Vous êtes prêts?
Laquelle de ces
*Alarme*
(Maxildan) Ah! J'entends une alarme.
J'entends une alarme et l'alarme c'est normalement un jeu un peu particulier
Quand vous allez entendre cette alarme à chaque Prime, ça veut dire qu'on va
Mettre en pause le jeu actuel et on va faire
Un duel. Un duel qu'on va appeller One Shot
Le principe, c'est qu'ici on va jouer aux fléchettes
Il va nous falloir un joueur de chaque côté
Vous allez avoir une seule fléchette
Et le gagnant va pouvoir directement
Remporter trois points
Qui a torché les fléchette ici? Je vous laisse réfléchir. Ici? Est-ce que l'on sait déjà?
Oh! Ça strat énormément!
*Zouloux*
(Maxildan) Alors?
(Squeezie) Et pour changer!
(Maxildan) Et c'est Zouloux qui va tout carry. Attends, Attends Zouloux! Ça veut dire que tu es hyper-chaud sur la fléchette?
De l'autre côté?
Vingt Cent Team?
(?) C'est Zank
(Zankioh) Ça va être moi
(Maxildan) C'est Zank, Vous pouvez l'applaudir s'il-vous-plait.
Zank qui va affronter Super-Zouloux sur
Une seule et unique fléchette, si vous la ratez, tant pis
Vous êtes prêts?
(Zouloux) Quelle est la distance?
(Maxildan) Vous avez une petite bandelette noire, je vous propose de vous mettre ici, ça me semble absolument parfait.
(Zouloux) Après toi.
(Maxildan) Zouloux, tu veux jouer en premier?
Tu joues d'ici ou de là?
(Zouloux) Tout à l'heure, j'ai frappé en premier, j'ai fait le meilleur score, donc bon
Je ne veux pas casser le suspense
(Maxildan) Oh là! Oh là! Ça se la pète énormément! T'as intérêt à assurer derrière.
*Roulement de tambours*
(Maxildan) Oh! Roulement de tambours
(Jiraya) Zank, fait pas le con
*Roulements de tambours*
*Rires*
*Applaudissements*
(Zouloux) C'est dedans, c'est dedans
(Maxildan) Un point, merveilleux
Parfait, un point
Zouloux, ça va être dur de faire pire, sauf si tu rates la cibles. Bonne chance à toi!
*Roulements de tambours*
(?) Tu peux pas le faire, mec
OOOOH! Non mais c'est pas vrai!
Oh le choc ! Oh le choc !
(Jiraya) Oh! What a shock !
(Maxildan) C'est absolument terrible. On vient de faire une égalité
Ben, du coup, qu'est-ce qui se passe quand il y a égalité
On va garder les règles normales. Égalité, ça veut dire un point chacun
Du coup, on passe à 5-5
Et ça reste super serré. Allez c'est partie. On peut les applaudir s'il-vous-plait
(Jiraya) Si c'est pas le water-polo mon gars
(Squeezie) Je suis choqué
Il y avait combien de chances sur combien pour qu'il se passe ça quoi?
(Maxildan) J'en était donc à une question un peu high-tech, un peu PC. Il y a des PCiste parmi vous?
*Ouais! Tout le monde*
(Maxildan) Ouais, tout le monde, voilà, génial, merveilleux.
Laquelle...
De ces cartes graphiques...
N'existe pas?
La 10-60?
La 10-70
La 10-80?
La 10 90?
(Malxildan) La 10-90, c'est une bonne réponse!
(Jiraya) Oh là là!
Oh le dev!
(Maxildan) On passe à la question suivante. Un point de plus pour la Vingt Cent Team. Six point
Petite musique, pour vous mettre un petit peu dans l'ambiance
*Musique*
Combien de nominations aux Oscars
Pour La la land?
8? 10? Oh!
(Xari) 14
(Maxildan) C'est une bonne réponse!
*Cris et applaudissements*
14 nominations!
Et on enchaîne avec une nouvelle question. C'est une question jeu vidéo
C'est un petit peu pointu, je vous préviens, mais c'est un peu pour vous jauger
On verra sur les prochains quiz.
Avant de sortir Horizon Zero Dawn, sur quoi
travaillaient ses développeurs? Ah?
*The Last of Us*
(Maxildan) Absolument pas. C'est Naughty Dog qui fait The Last...
*Allez Squeezie*
(Maxildan) Kill Zone proposé par le public est une bonne réponse, mais je ne vous attribue pas le point
(Squeezie) Je viens de le dire
(Maxildan) Tu as dit Kill Zone?
(Squeezie) J'ai dit Kill Zone
(Maxildan) Ok Ok, c'est bon
Il l'a dit, il l'a dit, c'est bon
Un point de plus pour la Team Burton Voilà ils sont à 7
La Vingt Cent Team est à 6.
Question suivante, une question dans la joie
Dans la bonne humeur, car on a passé une excellente année 2016, on s'est fait super plaisir
Je vais donc vous demander laquelle de ces célébrités
Est morte en premier?
Ah je n'ai pas changé.
Mohamed Ali
Georges Michael
David Bowie
Ou Prince ?
(Jiraya) C'est moi mec
Mohamed Ali, Georges Michael, David Bowie ou Prince?
(Jiraya) Je pense que c'est Mohamed Ali
(Maxildan) Mohamed Ali. Absolument pas. C'est une mauvaise réponse ! Vous avez tout le temps de répondre de ce côté-ci
(Squeezie) David Bowie
(Maxildan) David Bowie, c'est une bonne réponse, il est mort en janvier.
Paix son âme
David Bowie est mort en janvier, Prince est mort en avril, Mohamed Ali en juin et Georges Michael en décembre
(Squeezie) Est-ce que tu peux rappeler les scores? Juste comme ça
(Maxildan) 8 points pour la Team Burton, 6 points pour la Vingt Cent Team
On est en avance du côté de Squeezie
(Squeezie) Hey ouais!
Question jeux vidéos, on vient de jouer à la Nintendo Switch
Mais quel était son nom de code avant son annonce?
(Xari) Euh, NX
(Maxildan) C'est une bonne réponse, la Nintendo NX
(Squeezie) Xari! La machine!
(Maxildan) C'est la balle de match pour la team Burton (Squeezie) On l'appelle "la machine"
(Squeezie) Et les gars, si on gagne la prochaine, c'est gagné
(Maxildan) Question cinéma, ou plutôt people
Combien d'enfants
A Will Smith?
Alors ça a buzzé à droite et j'ai entendu le public qui souffle, s'il-vous-plait, ne soufflez pas
Deux?
C'est une mauvaise réponse
(Squeezie) Trois?
(Maxildan) Trois c'est une bonne réponse
Et mais vous avez gagné du coup, parce que vous êtes absolument à 10 points!
(Squeezie) *Cris*
(Squeezie) Bien joué les mecs!
(Maxildan) Et vous gagnez sur cette question!
Excellent taff ici pour la Team Burton, avec Xari, Squeezie, Gotaga, Super-Zouloux, Terracid, Manamy, ainsi que Sky
(Mickalow) J'ai une question
(Maxildan) Oui Micka je t'écoute
(Mickalow) Est-ce que parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup joué
(Maxildan) Venez, venez tous prêt de moi
(Mickalow) On n'a pas beaucoup joué et est-ce que Lucas serait prêt à remettre son titre en jeu sur la Force?
(Maxildan) À remettre son titre en jeu?
Ah! Est-ce que tu veux remettre ton titre en jeu sur La Force?
(Squeezie) Le mec il s'attaque à truc. Ah d'accord la régie est partie
(Maxildan) La régie s'est cassée
(Squeezie) Euh, mais tu t'attaques à une grenouille quoi
(Mickalow) Ah donc, tu perds tes couilles?
*Oooooohhhh*
(Maxildan) Je ne me mêlerai pas de ça
(Mickalow) Sur 104 viewers, 104 viewers qui sont là, genre, Ouah!
(Squeezie) Est-ce que je dois le faire?
*Cris*
(Maxildan) Ah! Tu remets ta victoire sur un coup de poing?
(Squeezie) Au pire la fléchette?
(Xari) À la fléchette
(Maxildan) À la fléchette?
(Mickalow) Non! Non!
(Maxildan) J'ai envie de te dire. Hey, tu sais ce que j'ai envie de te dire
C'est lui qui a gagné, donc c'est lui qui choisi le jeu
(Squeezie) Donc en fait la fléchette c'est du hasard, je l'annonce, c'est vraiment...
(Maxildan) Allez on y va! La fléchette c'est partie
(Squeezie) Honneur à toi, comme quand t'as choisi ton équipe
(Maxildan) Allez à toi Mickalow. Est-ce qu'on peut avoir des petits roulements de tambours en régie?
*Roulements de tambours*
Il a déjà fait tombé la fléchette, on n'est pas bien
(?) Donc c'est zéro point!
*Roulements de tambours*
(Maxildan) Est-ce qu'on peut le chauffer, s'il-vous-plait dans le public?
Oooooohhh!
(Maxildan) Elle est tombée, elle est tombé
(?) Nous fait pas une Zouloux
(Maxildan) Ne fait pas la même
Roulement de tambours. Attention
*Roulements de tambours*
*Ooooohhhh!!!*
36!
(Squeezie) Bien joué mon équipe!
(Maxildan) Et Squeezie ainsi que la Team Burton qui gagne toujours ce jeu et qui maintiennent leur prix
Bien joué à vous!
*Musique*
(Maxildan) Merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette émission
On a vraiment essayé de faire un show sympa
(Squeezie) Je veux remercier tous les gens qui ont participé de prêt ou de loin à ce projet
Que ce soit l'équipe technique
Que ce soit tous les streamers ici qui ont accepté de rejoindre le projet
Et Laink et Terracid qui ont accepté de venir en guest ce soir
(Maxildan) Merci à eux, on peut les applaudir!
(Squeezie) Merci beaucoup les mecs
Ça nous a fait super plaisir
Il y a aussi pleins de gens qui ont bossé dans l'ombre et dont vous avez même pas idées
(Maxildan) Ouais, merci à toute l'équipe technique derrière
(Squeezie) Tout l'équipe technique qui réalise le Prime,
Eli qui a grave aidé aussi
NewQuest qui a développé le site. Bref et j'en oublie probablement 2 000 autres
Mais merci à tous
Et merci à vous surtout (Maxildan) Merci à vous
On fait du bruit pour les gens qui regardent quand même
(Maxildan) Merci à Vous
*Bruit*
Merci beaucoup à vous et ça en plus, ce n'est que le Prime
Vous avez aussi la prog qui est disponible du coup sur le site
(Squeezie) dès demain
(Maxildan) Sous la chaîne
(Squeezie) On se retrouve demain, à midi sur la live tv
Moi je passerai peut-être dans le Récap de Max
À quelle heure?
(Maxildan) à 17 heures
(Squeezie) À 17 heures.  Et en attendant, je vous dis à bientôt
Et on finit sur des applaudissements!
(Maxildan) Merci à tous, salut, à la semaine prochaine!
(Squeezie) À Bientôt!
*musique*